le moins ça fait peur si on ne mettait
pas
assez d'essence soit sur le bateau sont
pas utilisées de sauvetage à ses mots
c'est rageant
s'il est bien nous attrape c'était fini
pour moi
ce qui arrive le temps c'est de voir que
c'est de plus en plus difficile de
justifier de ce raid
apparemment
on l'appelle la route de la méditerranée
[Musique]
un trajet emprunté depuis deux ans par
plus de 500 migrants de la libye ou la
tunisie vers l'italie
cette route est en fait un parcours à
obstacles souvent mortelle depuis le
2016 plus de 8600 personnes se sont
noyées en méditerranée en tentant la
traversée
un chiffre sans doute bien en deçà de la
réalité
aider les autres affrété par sos
méditerranée et médecins sans frontières
le navire de sauvetage
aquarius a déjà permis de secourir en
deux ans plus de 28000 personnes à son
bord des gens de toutes nationalités de
tous horizons
choqués par le drame qui se joue chaque
jour en méditerranée dans guilou était
marin pêcheur en bretagne lorsqu'il a
tout laissé tomber pour tenter
d'empêcher les cats ont autant que moi
sachs octobre à cette situation la
consternation via de la révolte
et puis à la conviction que la nécessité
d'agir romaniuk lui était auparavant
plongeurs professionnels maîtres nageurs
il coordonne aujourd'hui les activités
de recherche et de sauvetage à bord de
l'aquarius un travail fastidieux et
stressant un peu comme chercher une
aiguille dans une botte de foin
les bateaux et son petit on les voit pas
son radar
des fois il ya des avions qui passent
qui voit les bateaux au des fois c'est
peu lazare mans que nous on fait ne
patrouillent entre est et ouest
on continue avec les gens qui scrute
l'horizon pour trouver sept bateaux
parce que si on ne trouve pas c'est sûr
que les gens y vont mourir sur la
passerelle de l'aquarius les membres
d'équipage se relaie toutes les douze
heures ont observé la mer à la recherche
de bateau en détresse
alors qu'on la veille radio ont été
aussi constants
sur les bateaux sont en détresse le
plupart des gens rient sa femme âgée les
bateaux sont tellement fragile que
c'est 100% sûr qu'ils vont avoir le
problème les contraintes sont nombreuses
l'aquarius ne peut s'approcher à moins
de 25 milles nautiques des côtes
libyennes et la zone à couvrir et l âge
en attendant les sauvetages l'équipage
passe son temps à s'entraîner histoire
d'être prêt exercice de secours en mer
comme les soins et réanimation après une
semaine en mer la persévérance finit par
payer
pour lui pas reçu l'alerté ce matin pour
le bateau en détresse avec
150 personnes avant me suis levé nous
dès qu'on a reçu la lettre ce matin on a
vu
le promoteur en marché
envoûtés
dirige la raison pour assister
le bateau pneumatique a été repérée du
haut des airs
il est surchargé sur une mer démontée
un autre navire de sauvetage cia y
arriver juste avant a déjà distribué des
gilets de sauvetage mais l'équipage de
l'aquarius on doit faire vite la danse
ils ont des chances c'était très
dangereux
en plus cette habitude ces bateaux
semble très fragile
il risque de se casser
à tout moment les hauteurs de sos
méditerranée arrive d'abord de zodiac
rapide dans gi dirige les opérations pas
mal de choses faciles pas le contact
facile ou pas la stabilité du
réaction
daniel de médecins sans frontières
repère un passager dia l'air inconscient
il est d'évacuer en priorité sur une
civière pour recevoir immédiatement des
soins à bord de l'aquarium
la priorité c'est d'extraire les gens en
situation médicale on va dire donc qui
sont soit déjà inconscient soit sur le
point de sur le point de devenir
danse dans l'évacuation se poursuit
les femmes et les enfants d'abord
marie thérèse l'homo c'est la fin d'un
long calvaire
j'avais très peu
à la pluie
mettez ajouté ils nous ont dit de rester
tranquille et suivre
les instructions tout va bien se passer
ona les 164 passagers du bateau
pneumatique sont ramenés à bord de
l'aquarius la plupart viennent d'afrique
de l'ouest
ces gens vient tous de passer plus de 12
heures à bord d'un bateau pneumatique en
pleine mer ils sont tous exténué
déshydraté et ils sont en vie après une
nuit de sommeil
viel envie de dire merci l'envi aussi de
célébrer la vie
à
c'est impressionnant leur capacité
vouloir vivre coûte que coûte et
être heureux lui
on est impressionné leurs maisons
là
car il faut dire que c'est passager de
l'aquarius reviennent de loin
il ya surtout beaucoup de gens qui ont
été battus poignardé frappé kidnappés
dans leur trajet il ya des personnes qui
ont fait 1 1 m 200 m eur trajet à à
travers de la libye
si mamadou salif diallo quoi tu sais
qu'il a été frappé à coups de barres de
fer par les passeurs avant d'embarquer
dans le bateau un épisode presque banal
pour ce maçon guinéen d'arriver en libye
pour travailler il ya deux ans il s'est
retrouvé victime d' esclavage de les
tensions et des percussions de torture
il n'a que 21 ans
il semble en avoir 20 de plus olivier
très difficile on prenait les enfants
c'est des animaux pour frapper sa
pouvoir ça pour passer pour des frappes
et je travaille avec pas trop il la
définit
sita réclamait à salers qui fait sorti
son physique on te prends mais dans les
prisons réclament l'argent pour appeler
sa part ils vont bien la race et non
pétiller
marquante est aussi la libye est devenue
synonyme d'enfer
âgé d'à peine 16 ans son objectif
n'était pourtant pas de venir en europe
s'il s'est embarqué sur un bateau
c'était simplement pour fuir l'horreur
les kidnappings le racket la violence
constante à l'endroit des noirs on n'est
jamais au présent pour nous fait payer
l'argent pour qu'on puisse sorti il y en
a qui disent devoir n'aura pas très
nerveux pas de rapatriement
c'était pour me faire souffrir sur le
mans nous frapper en voyant que leurs
sauveteurs étaient trop bien
les migrants étaient soulagés car en mer
il est des terrorisé à l'idée d'être
intercepté par des gars de groupe
bien et ramener sur leur lieu de départ
si les jib libyenne nous attrape c'était
fini pour eux
c'est à finir pour depuis quelques mois
la situation a beaucoup changé en
méditerranée là c'est face à l'afflux de
réfugiés
l'italie est fourni des bateaux rapides
ou verre de côtes libyens et leur
convient de plus en plus de missions
d'interception
dans la nuit un appel est reçu en
cernant bateau en détresse avec 70
personnes à bord mais le centre de
coordination des secours
l'as rome confie la mission à la garde
côtière libyenne
aquarius se dirige quand même sur place
au kazoo mais une fois arrivé c'est le
spectacle désolant de bateau vide qui
attend l'équipage
de toute évidence l'équipage de
l'aquarius est arrivé trop tard des gens
qui se trouvaient à bord de ce radeau
ont été interceptés par la garde-côtes
ligne n il faut actuellement en route
vers la libye sur l'aquarius la
déception et la frustration sont
évidentes
l'incompréhension aussi vis-à-vis des
nouvelles politiques italiennes car
selon le droit maritime
les rescapés doivent être débarquer dans
un port jugées sûres
pour nous c'est ma façon forcément
facile sésame est agréable de marteau
rien en faire
mais l'équipage doit rester motivé et
concentré
deux autres embarcations en détresse
sont signalés à proximité dont ce bateau
de bois avec à son bord plus de 200
migrants
un sauvetage délicat ces bateaux qui
sont très instables
donc si un trop de points d'un côté ils
peuvent chavirer
on essaie d'éviter à tout prix les
mouvements de panique le mouvement de
masse l'aquarius l'ange toutes ses
ressources dans l'opération pour être
prête à tout
trois zodiac des bouées géantes des
radios gonflables et surtout des genêts
sauvetage pour tout le monde
une opération bien rodée basé sur
l'expérience
la clé du succès le calme et la méthode
les gilets total sont distribués les
passagers secourus et ramenés sur
l'aquarius ils sont plus de 200 au total
dont un tiers de femmes la plupart
viennent d'erythrée
mais l'urgence n'est pas terminée car il
faut en même temps venir en aide à ce
bateau pneumatique avec à son bord 68
personnes fortement incommodées par des
fuites de carburant
après trois sauvetages en trois jours il
n'y a maintenant plus de 450 migrants à
bord de l'aquarius mais ce n'est pas
encore terminé
nous faisons maintenant route vers le
nord pour récupérer 78 autres migrants
qui ont été secourus plus tôt par la
garde côtière italienne
après le transfert l'aquarius met le cap
sur la sicile direction trapani port de
débarquement pour ses compagnons
d'infortuné ils sont 5 137 de 25
nationalités différentes et de toutes
religions
le matin mais la fébrilité est palpable
pour les passagers de la voiture qui
s'apprêtait des partis sur une terre
inconnue
je chantais parce que j'ai de la joie au
caire pour tout le monde
vraiment c'est exceptionnel l'aigle et
de joie on peut pas l'imaginer le monde
c'est là tout le monde espère qu' avoir
les convie les papiers à voir le travail
passé une folie tout ce que je vois ici
c'est la même idée est très contents
morey devient en fait réalité des
sentiments de soulagement et
d'anticipation largement partagée au
moment quitter le navire de faire les
premiers pas sur un continent dont ils
ont tant rêver six migrants ne savent
pas encore ce qui les attend en europe
ils sont portés par une certitude rien
ne peut être pire que le cauchemar
qu'ils viennent de vivre dans l'enfer de
la limite
au nom tout ça à ses fils monaco